ceci est un spectacle d'un spectacle
unique en son genre
la première lui à première vue seulement
ce n'est qu'un décor qui bouge pas de
textes par des intrigues pas de comédien
du moins immédiatement visible en fait
il ya des comédiens mais ils sont cachés
sous une sorte de cuirasse bariolés
visage compris ce sont des marionnettes
vivant ce spectacle est intitulé coucou
bazar il est montré au public tous les
jours à 18h30 à paris sous la nef du
grand palais des champs elysées
l'auteur de coucou bazar est un peintre
il s'appelle jean dubuffet une
exposition importante de ses oeuvres
présentées en même temps dans ce même
grand palais par le centre national
d'art moderne
c'est dire l'importance qu'on lui
accorde officiellement cependant bien
que français jean dubuffet est maintenu
et peut-être moins apprécié en france
qu'aux états unis où on le tient en
haute estime
il a commencé à peindre avec des
matériaux choisis en fonction de leur
extrême pauvreté apparente quelque chose
qui ressemblait à de la boue dans cette
boue il a fait progressivement
apparaître des formes élémentaires
c'était une sorte d'art brut
l'expression est d'ailleurs d'une bille
puis il l'afp un des formes plus
complexes et forme entremêlées sorte de
base eau qui l'a appelé pour look il a
découvert dans ses pas une débauche de
personnages fantastiques issus du hasard
il en a fait naître ce qu'il appelle
lui-même des bons hommes
il a séparé c'est beau comme du reste de
ses peintures
les a sculpté dans du polyester et a
voulu leur donner une vie autonome d'où
l'idée de fabriquer des costumes rigide
à l'image de ces bons hommes d'en
revêtir des comédiens taylor le
spectacle que vous voyez et aînés c'est
un spectacle qui est intermédiaire un
point entre la peinture et le théâtre
c'était ou qui est à la fois l'année
l'autre c'est une extension de la
peinture
les peintures qui sont généralement
confinés dans un rectangle là ne le sont
plus sont découpées et elles sont
expansé de telle manière que c'est comme
un tableau dans lequel on entre
finalement j'ai l'impression que ça
entre en concurrence avec le théâtre et
que c'est de nature à a donné des idées
nouvelles sur des spectacles théâtraux
en bref le coucou bazar du grand palais
des champs elysées ce spectacle sans
paroles premier du genre c'est du
théâtre pain ou plus exactement de la
peinture animé